[Music]
kenny is with us in south carolina hi
kenny what's up
hey sir um
just started listening to your show
today uh while i was traveling and and
honestly i guess
with your new book coming out um you've
kind of been in the forefront of some
things the last few days i've had
friends in the past that talked about
some of your philosophies and that kind
of thing but
with most things i thought it was
getting to the point where i could be
debt-free i thought i had to have money
in order to do so
um my biggest question after listening
to you and and hear some of these very
inspiring stories including georgia's
today uh congratulations on your debt
free oh thanks as well sir
um but i want to get to that point
myself but our problem is we live
paycheck to paycheck and and we're
taking care of some um our elderly
parents and that type of thing
and and we don't have a lot of
disposable income at the end of the
month um as a matter of fact in some
months we
we do have to extend things out with
credit cards and that type of thing but
we want to get to that point all right
i'll tell you what george is going to
jump in and give you a plan before i
before i forget though i'm gonna go
ahead and tell kelly we're gonna put you
on hold and send you a copy of the new
book baby steps millionaire and a copy
of total money make over both that's a
one-two punch that'll get you rolling
brother but georgia give you a line up
here well kenny uh thank you so much for
for checking out the show and and
giving us a call that's incredible that
you just were listening today and
decided to call in so tell me about your
situation what's your household income
and how much debt do you have
um
we
make gross about 75 to 80 000 a year
and right now we're probably
300 350 000 in debt does that include
your house or is that just consumer debt
uh that is house student loans and
vehicle and that type of thing okay well
let's separate the house for now let's
put that aside how much consumer debt do
you have outside of the house
um
the student loans in the vehicle
probably
200 of that wow
okay and how much of that is vehicle
um 22 000. okay so 150 in student loans
50 in a car or cars
and 150 on the house
okay all right and are you guys doing a
monthly budget right now
or is this new to you um
well we
i know what my budget is my wife is her
fluctuates a bit because
like i say her um situation with her
mother you know we
we're paying some bills for them to
supplement what they're not getting
based off social security and retirement
and that type of thing
um they live with you you know we
um
my mother does
but her mother does not
okay
are you guys covering your four walls
right now are you able to cover food
utility shelter transportation without
issues
uh yeah for the most part okay well at
that point you've got stable income and
you're stable on on those fronts and
you're making all of your payments on
your bills
yes sir okay
how much do you have cash right now in
liquid savings and
everything um
my savings we probably got
10 to 12 000 to the side okay
and uh how much do you love these cars i
mean could you sell these cars right now
and help speed up this process of paying
off some debt and get something cheaper
um possibly yes
okay
is it one car or two they're 50.
what's the expensive one
um new truck
and it's how much just purchased how
much um
the debt on it's about 35 000 yeah all
right
okay
well you
kenny you asked and so we're going to
tell you
all right number one thing is when you
guys sit down together you and your wife
together combine your efforts combine
your incomes and combine your messes
okay your messes are the debt the
household that you got to support
a little help for her mom and dad that
aren't there a little help for your mom
that is there or vice versa or whatever
it is whatever it's taking to cause
these things to happen but we are now
one we don't run two different things
you're not roommates you're husband and
wife we're going to be on one
budget matter of fact we're going to go
even further than send you those two
books i'm going to go ahead and put you
into ramsey plus which signs you up for
financial peace university to go through
the class
and you and your wife can go through
that together you can either go to a
local church and go through it or you
can go online and watch the videos
either way or both for that matter so
i'm going to give you the full freaking
enchil enchilada truck
i think you're going to do it all but
here's what you're going to end up doing
it may take you a little while to get
there emotionally
but the two of you combining all of your
income and then giving every dollar a
name on purpose before the month begins
part of ramsey plus is the every dollar
budgeting software makes it very very
easy to do you don't need to be an
accountant you don't have to be any good
as software anything like that this is
going to make it like like using a
yellow pad to lay out a budget in detail
but if you do it in detail and you do it
together you're going to feel like you
got a raise because there's a level of
waste in all the disorganization there
always is for all of us and you're not
an exception the second thing is you
shouldn't have a vehicle that is 50 of
your dad gum income especially when it's
in debt and especially when you've got
all these other households you're trying
to support and especially when you've
got this much student loan debt so i'm
sorry brother but that truck's gone it
was insanity when you bought it and
we're going to get rid of it because i
want you to get your life back so you
can drive anything you want to drive in
a few years i'm not saying you never do
that in your life but i'm saying at this
stage of the game you're broke you can't
pay attention you call the national
radio show saying i can't even make
bills without going into credit card
debt every month and so i've got
something's got to change here
and so i'm you know we're about to
about to clean this mess up and it's
going to get radical and we're going to
be on beans and rice rice and beans
we're not going to see the inside of a
restaurant unless we're working there as
an extra job we're not going on vacation
we've got a dadgum mess to clean up here
and you just draw back your fist and you
punch a hole in this wall man that's
what you're going to do and we're going
to show you how to do that with great
intensity with your wife together and
i'm also going to say that the set of
parents that are living on social
security that aren't under your roof
we're probably going to put them on a
budget too because they need to get
their crap together so you don't have to
support them they need to live on what
they've got coming in if at all possible
i don't want to go hungry i'm not trying
to be mean but they're probably doing
the same kind of junk they may have a
drug car sitting in the driveway you're
paying the payment on indirectly
screwing around with this stuff so
you've got to clean up clean up clean up
clean up yeah you sell this truck it's
going to kick start this whole process
and the book and ramsey plus it'll lay
all this out for you but you're gonna
have a starter emergency fund of a
thousand dollars so take all that out of
savings and the rest of the money you
now have is gonna go towards those debts
from smallest to largest regardless of
the interest rate take five thousand of
the ten thousand go buy you a five
thousand dollar truck to drive for right
now do you get this mess cleaned up no
payments boom i just got rid of 750
bucks a month i love it kenny call us
back when you're debt-free call us back
if you want more encouragement